-Welcome.
You and I go way back,
and I just want
to tell this story just so that
you know how much I think about
you and speak about you a lot.
I was a stand-up comedian,
and it was probably 1996 or '97.
-'97, yeah.
-It was before I was on
"Saturday Night Live."
I was doing stand-up.
I got a gig to open for you
at the Universal Amphitheater
in Los Angeles.
-Yep.
-And so I went.
I said hi to you and Davy.
But you said to me --
You go,
"Hey, what's your name again?
It was Jimmy?"
I go, "Yeah."
You go, "I think you got
something there, kid."
-Yeah.
-And I go -- and I go,
"Oh, thank you so much."
I'm freaking out meeting you.
And you go, "I'm actually
directing this pilot.
If you want to audition,
have your manager
call this guy
you're working with."
-Yeah.
-And you gave me an audition.
I don't know
if the show went anywhere.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I wanted to tell you,
it built my confidence
as a comedian and someone who
couldn't get a gig
or get a callback or anything.
That little boost,
that little
someone believing in you
really meant a lot to me.
-Oh, thank you.
-And I'll never forget it,
and I really thank you so much.
-Oh, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're a good man.
And I was freaking out
because there's another
famous Jimi
who opened for you, as well.
This is a famous --
do you know -- funny story.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, this is --
if you look right here,
Jimi Hendrix
opened for you guys.
-Yeah.
-What was Jimi Hendrix like?
-Wonderful, wonderful guy.
I was in New York,
and I was -- earlier on,
before he was Jimi Hendrix.
And somebody said, "You gotta
go down to the Cafe Au Go Go,
see this guitar player who's
playing with
John Hammond's band."
I went down there,
and sure enough --
And they said he was known
as this guy
that plays guitar
with his teeth.
We were looking
for an opening act.
And I suggested them,
opening for the headlining act
can be a problem sometimes
for the opening act.
Well, it was -- I'm not kidding.
It was --
♪ Purple haze come in my brain ♪
-Yeah, yeah.
-"We want Davy!
We want The Monkees!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, "We want The Monkees."
-♪ Foxy lady ♪
"Micky!"
-"Dolenz!"
[ Laughter ]
-Terrible nightmare
for Jimi Hendrix.
-Oh, it was embarrassing.
-You have so many stories,
and you actually
have an announcement
that you're gonna make tonight.
You're actually --
These photos that you have
throughout all the years,
you're finally publishing them.
-Yep.
A book that is called --
[ Applause ]
-It's a big deal.
-A book coming out
in November called
"I'm Told I Had a Good Time."
[ Laughter ]
-That is
a great title right there.
That is fantastic.
"I'm Told --"
-So true.
-I'd kick myself
if I didn't ask.
'Cause I know
you're going on tour.
You're about to play --
You're celebrating The Monkees.
-Yeah.
-But I would kick myself
if I didn't ask if you would
like to --
Can you sing something?
-Oh, I'd love to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd love to.
I'm sorry.
I can't, 'cause I need a
tambourine to sing, and I --
[ Tambourine rattling ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Micky Dolenz,
ladies and gentlemen.
"Last Train to Clarksville."
♪♪
♪ Take the last train
to Clarksville ♪
♪ I'll meet you at the station ♪
♪ You can be here by 4:30 ♪
♪ I'll make your reservation ♪
♪ Don't be slow ♪
♪ Oh, no, no, no ♪
♪ Oh, no, no, n-o-o-o ♪
♪ And I don't know
if I'm ever comin' home ♪
-Micky Dolenz right there,
ladies and gentlemen!
For tickets to "The Monkees
Celebrated by Micky Dolenz,"
go to mickydolenz.com.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around!
-♪ Take the last train
to Clarksville ♪
Yeah!
♪ Take the last train
to Clarksville ♪
♪♪
♪ Take the last train
to Clarksville ♪
♪ Last train, last train,
last train, last train ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]